hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between otto thunderson and paul
charles morphe this is game seven and so
far uh a lot has happened now in the
previous game anderson was only down by
two points so if he won game six uh he
would lower that to a one point margin
the problem is uh he just couldn't do it
morphy allowed him chances but he simply
uh you know couldn't uh hit that final
nail uh so to say uh and the well the
opportunity went away uh which is a
pretty big deal because now he's still
in the match this is game seven and he's
down by three points and that's a lie
you have to beat morphy three times just
you know get get even with him uh
luckily for him uh draws don't count so
you can get as many draws as you want as
long as you win three games you're gonna
you're gonna equalize at some point so
again understand in the game seven gets
the white pieces i don't know why for
some reason in the olden days they would
play like okay i have white you have
black and white you have black and then
let's say after six games then i will
repeat uh i will have black twice or
white twice in this matter uh and it's
uh it's uh pretty great because anderson
again goes for his uh well famous a3
opening and we discussed in the previous
game that he was gonna go for this one
three times but let's see what he uh
what he decided to change now maybe he
didn't decide to do anything maybe it
was morphe who deviated uh from a
certain line so okay let's check it out
this is game seven uh match of the of
this century so
let's see what happened so anderson
again with the white pieces opens with a
three uh sorry about that and we're not
gonna dwell too long on the opening
because it's the exact same one from the
previous video
so i suggest you check out that one now
if you haven't already or you know
better yet check out the entire morphe
saga uh the link is in the description
below uh so e5 by morphe we have c4
knight to f6 and not knight to c3
we have d5 captures captures and now e3
so again going for the reverse sicilian
with the white pieces uh we have bishop
to e6 by morphe going for his standard
development bishops to e6 and d6 and now
knight to f3 attacking the e5 pawn
bishop to d6 morphe defends and now
bishop to e2 we have castles by morphy
and d4 now by anderson
we said that uh two of the games will
feature the d4 move one of the games
will feature castles instead of d4 but
okay morphe repeats everything the same
as in the previous game bishop capture
knight captures on c3 b captures and now
e4 chasing away the knight knights the
d2 and now f5 so everything exactly the
same we have f4 and now we reach the
position where in the previous game
morphe decided to play uh well sort of
in great style and he uh bust open the
position with the g5 but we mentioned
that this is maybe a bit too risky maybe
just e captures an f3 alpha
or queen to h4 that gives black uh you
know a game without much issue so here
morphe goes for queen to h for check and
it is only now as of move 11 that we
have a completely new game
uh so let's see how anderson defends he
defends exactly uh how we mentioned he
should defend in the previous video so
g3 queen to h3 and now bishop to f1
chasing the morphy's queen back queen to
h6 and now c4 he just grabs more space
in the center and this is not a problem
here he's just going to play king to f2
develop the light square bishop
somewhere and continue his development
we have c6 by morphe and now c5 uh
pushing the this bishop even further
back we have bishop to c7 now yes
morphy's b7 pawn is a backward spawn but
that's a lot to
uh you know it's not really a problem if
you go for example rook to b1 uh we can
just play b5 so it's never an issue if
captures alpha sound and just captures
and you know black is perfectly fine
here so instead after bishop to c7 we
have bishop to c4 anderson it definitely
makes the case for developing the bishop
like this because now if bishop captures
uh knight is gonna capture on c4 and
then the d6 square or the e5 square will
be a very nice outpost for the knight at
some point but morphy says nope if you
want to trade you're welcome to capture
on e6 my queen is covering that very
nicely i'm just going to continue
developing
we have castles by anderson and now b5
by morphe now he's saying okay move the
bishop then i'm going to play a5 and
then at some point create a pass pawn
would maybe move like b4 so anderson
capture some b6 alpha song we have eight
captures and now queen to b3 with a
double attack on the bishop here rook
after e8 defending and now just bishop
to b2 so anderson still trying to keep
everything in the game not trading too
much
uh he wants to he wants to create some
winning chances of course without giving
morphy too much as he would really hate
being down four points in the match
already so we have b5 by morphy uh
forcing the the trade here we have
bishop capture sunny six queen captures
and now anderson doesn't want to trade
queens anderson just place a queen to c2
not with continued pressure on the c6
pawn probably if anderson wasn't such a
you know an attacking mad genius uh he
would play something like rook after c1
say okay i'm going to continue putting
pressure here and you're welcome to
trade here i'm going to capture with my
knight and you know
if you're all that eager
you know of trading queens so instead
after queen captures an e6 we have queen
to c2 uh anderson uh says that uh his
chances of winning are much greater of
course if the queens stay on the board
and now morphy plays queen to d5 you
could also consider maybe a move like
bishop d6 you could all go knight v6 to
c for also an idea uh but morphy decides
uh for the nice centralizing queen to d5
and later on he might play something
like c5 and so on play put the rook on
c8 all depending on what anderson plays
so here we have rook f the c1 now
attacking the c6 pawn twice and rook to
a6 morphe defends it like this and this
rook will now either come maybe to see
it or maybe double up on the a file uh
we have a4 by anderson and now morphy
has to decide does he want to double up
the rooks on the a file or maybe a move
like b4 could be played he does get the
past b pawn and then let's say queen c4
you have to trade queens here captures
captures attack the attacks the pass
pawn now bishop d6 and we play uh this
game where black is is definitely fine
uh but white also has a pass pawn so you
know it's it's uh hard to hard to make
what's what here so instead after a4 we
have rook 8 to e8
uh sorry rook e the a8 doubling up on
the a file and now a captures on b5 we
have queen captures on b5 and now queen
to c4 with check now anderson trades
queens like this we have queen captures
knight captures and morphy now trades uh
a rook on a1 uh of course you could
capture with the rook and then morphe
would trade the other rook as well but
anderson wants to keep as much material
on the board as possible so bishop
captures on a1
and knight to f6 now and now we have
this end game where the material is
completely even both players have a dark
square bishop so completely even uh same
same number of pawns so how do you how
do you continue here uh well we have
bishop to c3 and now comes rook to a2 so
morphy gets a very very active uh
position for his rook and anderson uh
has to deal with this otherwise he will
not be able to bring the king into the
game you don't you know you don't really
want to overextend with those pawns and
you kind of want to start bringing your
king into the game so bishop to d2 cut
the rook off of the second rank and now
the king can come into the game so okay
knights to d5 by morphy king to f1 we
have bishop to d8 uh and now king to e1
we have bishop to e7 uh and now rook to
b1 preparing to uh you know uh
well play some like rook to b7 or rook
to b8 all depending on what uh what
morphe plays and it's not all that uh
all that simple yeah morphe plays h6 uh
then now comes knight to e5 attacking
the c6 pawn but now
everything morphe did was preparation
for this so now just c5 we have
characters captures um our pawns get
traded on c5 and now comes rook to b5
attacking morphy's bishop here but there
is one move that morphy can play here
that really makes uh makes a difference
in the position so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the only
good move for morphe while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations uh on finding the
only move that doesn't lose and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's knight captures on e3 and a special
bonus for you uh this move was praised
by none other than johanna blumenthal uh
so uh you know if you found knight
captures on e3 you were personally
praised by yohanyako blumenthal and he
said that this was very prettily played
i think this is the first time i've
actually heard the word prettily used in
a sentence especially to describe a
chess move so you know just prettily
um but okay uh the point is that uh now
if you capture on c5 which of course you
can uh then uh well then comes uh what
happened in the game but if you go for
bishop captures on e3 then we just play
bishop captures on e3 and morphy is up
upon and he's now of course better so
rook captures on c5 is the only way to
continue uh this is what anderson plays
and now comes knight to g2 with check
this is what morphy had in mind and now
it doesn't really matter what anderson
plays if king to f1 morphy just picks up
the bishop and the knight is defended so
king to f1 is out of the question if you
play king to d1 then e3 is coming
attacking the bishop and once the bishop
moves or you know doesn't does really
matter what you do he do check king to
c1 we're gonna bring the queen into the
game and now anderson has to give back
the material and you know it's a pretty
equal end game not pretty it's
completely equal end game
so after night at the g2 check we have
king the e2 anderson says all right this
move is maybe the one that gives me the
most chances but it's uh pretty much the
same morphe just plays e3 now the bishop
cannot move and now knight to f3 by
anderson we have g6 by morphe now the
rook is attacking the uh f5 pawn so g6
and now rook to d5 they're adding
another defender to the bishop here
and here morphy makes a fatal mistake
here you have to play
very very carefully
uh a move like king to f8 is possible
king the g7 is possible uh e captures
and d2 is possible so all of these moves
are possible but the morphe out of the
nowhere
i mean out of nowhere plays a move that
uh loses the game on the spot he plays
king to f7 and there's something uh very
very special about this move we could
even make this a thumbnail maybe i'm
still you know considering it uh but uh
this move loses the game and you know
for a very specific reason so feel free
to pause the video here and finally win
the game for anderson while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
finding this well quite an elusive idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook to a5 rook to
a5 such a such a great move uh and it
just shows you how how tricky uh of a
position is after morphe plays king to
f7
the main thing about king to f7 is that
the king is now in reach of the knight
knights the e5 will come with check so
now the problem is uh if morphe just uh
for example captures here uh it's not
enough uh going to capture with the
knight and after he captures king
captures there's nothing you can do here
this is completely unplayable the knight
is trapped there there's no escaping for
this night and uh white will simply you
know bring the king in and pick up the
knight and even if it wasn't it'd still
be very hard but now it's completely
lost so the only thing you could do
after a move like rook to a5 is avoided
the trade while still keeping an eye on
the bishop here but now comes knight to
e5 with check king to e6 and knight to
c4 and now we defend the bishop again
but we also attack the rook so we take
away the a2 square the b to square and
now the rook is left only with the c2
square to defend this bishop but this is
insufficient because the knight also
attacks the e3 pawn so knight captures
on e3 knight characters king captures
and anderson is now up a full piece so
incredible as it is uh but uh morphy
allowed this by playing king to f7 but
anderson did not play it i mean uh
how
who would expect morphe to you know play
the only move that loses the game
basically i mean you could play king g7
king to f8 you could play uh
e captures on d2 like ev everything is
perfectly fine but murphy finds the one
move that loses the game and uh i guess
anderson simply wasn't expecting it and
you know it's really
tough for anderson because uh morphe
will give you one and a half chance
every game to maybe beat him if you're
playing really well and here
was one such chance that anderson did
not take advantage of so king to f7
anderson played rook to d6 just keeping
an eye on the sixth rank but now morphy
just goes back king to g7 we have h4 and
now e captures on d2 we have rook
captures on d2 and now rook to a4
uh this could be the position that
anderson saw because if uh well for
example if morphe traded here characters
captures amorphy's knight is trapped
here but morphy uh had all of this uh
covered he just played rook to
rook to a4 and now it's not a problem
now king to f2 anderson attacks morphy's
knight but not knight captures an f4 and
if anderson uh maybe
well if he knew what morphe was gonna do
with the knight maybe he would have
stopped there and searched a bit more
for that rook day five move because
they're playing with unlimited time uh
no and when i say unlimited i mean uh
limited only by how great of a gentleman
you are uh so you know take that while
considering it's unlimited uh but yeah
now knight captures on f4 we have g
captures rook captures and now uh yes
anderson is up a piece but morphe is up
to pawns that the pawns are on the same
side of the board this is uh this is a
draw even with uh even with computer
precision there's there's no uh no no
achieving anything here so here we have
rook to d4 anderson forces a rook trade
with rook captures not like that but
rook captures on d for knight captures
and now king to f6 we have king to e3 we
have g5 and now anderson has to keep one
pawn in the game to ensure uh well he at
least has winning chances at some point
uh takes away this square from the king
with king to e5 and now knight to f3
check uh forcing the black king to go
back king of six anderson repeated
knights to d4 and he was in this
position and move 50 that anderson and
morphy agreed to a draw uh so after six
incredibly fighting games uh which of
which five ended uh well with with a
decisive result uh game seven ends in a
draw
so uh anderson really uh achieved a lot
in these two games even though he lost
one and drew one uh but he had uh
excellent winning chances against morphe
in the previous game and here he was
just outright winning i mean rook to a5
wins the game so really tough for
anderson that a3 opening uh
uh it definitely has its merits but you
know you have to take advantage of that
one and a half uh time uh that morphe
will allow you to beat him when you play
against him
uh so yeah that's again game seven of
this incredible match hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you are uh having a
great saturday uh i would like to thank
francis air tom derallo uh anthea in new
orleans uh pablo mohan and richard
yarnell for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga uh until it ends uh so thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your weekend